welcome back to liberal media freaking
out over Elon musk's attempt to bring
Free Speech back to Twitter
when talking about this it's you know
it's kind of funny how Elon Musk wants
to be sure massive life and Globe alter
altering consequences for just letting
people run wild on the thing there's
also a lot of folks out there that say
you know it's troubling enough that
private companies control these key
communication platforms around the world
maybe it's even worse to have the
world's richest person trying to buy one
of them and take it private are there
any ways to stop him if he wants to buy
Twitter are there any guard rails around
something like this because this could
be a very dangerous president last night
musk offered to buy Twitter for 43
billion dollars in cash oh my God he
could do so much with that money address
world hunger fix climate change hey you
Ding-A-Ling Twitter is already an
international platform for free speech
you know how I know that because no one
at Twitter can stop me from tweeting
suck at Elon Musk in every language
freaking out meanwhile the terminal
Twitter is ramping up the company in
acting a so-called poison pill to stop
Musk from taking over but it could hurt
the company financially and get this
employees are complaining that must ruin
their calm Focus week uh Kennedy oh no
no this week we better shut some people
down
to Washington Post columnist Max boot
it's like you're frightened this is what
scares you Elon Musk wanting to expand
free speech in this country when so much
speech is being curtailed uh when kids
and moms are being bombed to death
trying to escape Ukraine and you're
seeing that every day in real time and
this is what frightens you uh your
priorities are so incredibly out of line
this could be a great thing I don't
understand no one has any data or
examples to back up why they're freaking
out about this it's just that Twitter
won't have all of the mechanisms to shut
people down who don't engage in right
think all you have to do is walk around
the building and talk to people who have
been silenced on Twitter for no good
reason look at the Babylon bee look at
the New York Post it's really incredible
the reach that they have and the Damage
they can do when people haven't done any
harm in the first place other than share
ideas and talk and make jokes tires
they're freaking out and he's a
Libertarian what if he was a
conservative a republican I think more
important than what his political
aspirations is for any children out
there or young men women striving for
greatness this is what's nice when you
have Fu money you can do things like
that some rich people get spite stores
you ever you know where you went to a
barber shop and he upset you so you made
a barber shop right next to him because
you had that kind of money
musk took it to the next level he's
making Twitter his spite store so I love
it as somebody who likes to see people
get their comeuppance this has nothing
to do with free speech this is
he's going to kick in the door on the
fraternity he's going to allow everyone
to be in the fraternity and they don't
like that and journalists who use
Twitter for everything now are gonna
have to do their work because there's
going to be two this is a crazy idea
there's going to be dare I say it two or
three sides to an argument and you won't
be able to suppress things like the
hunter by the situation you won't be
able to cancel somebody who's loud and
controversial anymore and that's just
really ruining my day and my first world
problems so Jessica do we have this all
wrong give us the liberal perspective
why are your folks freaking out
so I have I asked the moderate liberal
perspectives on this um so you want to
be Peacemaker at the table after the Abe
ape for sure
so Elon Musk is certainly no
conservative and as a Libertarian he's
really more the way I think about him is
a green Eco Warrior right that should
make everyone on the left super happy
with what's going on with Tesla and he
also kept the internet alive in Ukraine
so we went from you know three weeks ago
like this is the greatest guy in the
entire world to this now that doesn't
mean that I don't understand being
apprehensive about a billionaire having
this much of a controlling stake but for
people who weren't upset about Jeff
Bezos taking over The Washington Post
which is arguably more influential if
you look at it you know top two or three
newspapers in the country you don't have
a lake to stand on one thing that I read
about that I thought was really
interesting was one of musk's key points
is that he wants the algorithm that
Twitter uses to rank its content to be
made public and that's actually
something that a lot of Executives at
Twitter themselves want to be done so I
feel like there's some way so you
support this I no I'm certainly not
ready to say that I listen I'm I'm not a
share holder I think shareholders should
have a role in this conversation it
shouldn't just be about the board this
poison pill strategy
um I I don't work at CNBC I cannot get
into the details of all of this but I
think that the points that he's making
it would be worthwhile as a nine percent
you know stakeholder for them to
consider them and maybe find some common
place where he doesn't become the
majority shareholder and he already said
he doesn't have the 43 billion in liquid
assets to be able to buy this anyway but
maybe we can move forward together in a
positive direction judge I am not a
shareholder and I do not work for CNBC
and I am thrilled that Elon Musk May own
Twitter and I'll tell you why because
the man believes in free speech
unadulterated Free Speech limited quote
the only limits on Free Speech should be
the legal limits imposed by the
government this is a man who is a
constitutionalist a man who believes in
the rule of law a man who doesn't
believe as the left believes that if
their ideology is at stake and their
political presidency is at stake that we
should therefore suppress the truth and
therefore we cannot allow anyone to
speak when it might impact a
presidential election this is a guy who
the left is right it will have globe and
life-altering consequences it will have
a dangerous precedent in their mind
because they don't believe in the free
speech that each one of us has been
raised to understand Free Speech isn't
about the the people who are triggered
or or who need a place to cry free
speech is the ability to say what you
want to other people as long as it is as
it is not criminal period I hope he buys
it and I hope he does what what we were
what we were just talking about and that
is that we should know what algorithms
are emphasize and de-emphasize so there
is real truth on Twitter
you're done I'm cooked there you go hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else